gallop also did the 2014 most admired
women so let's take a look at that list
Hillary Clinton number one are we having
Hillary fatigue at Oprah Winfrey Malala
condi rice Michelle Obama Angelina Jolie
sarah palin Princess Kate Elizabeth
Warren Laura Bush so again very
political heavy me decide yep sattar
than the men's list right and as and it
is because I guess there are more men
who are famous for being I don't know I
mean not a Kim Kardashian type but more
of substance but Laura but Laura Bush
right so George Bush was on the other
one but Laura Bush and so Laura Bush
crazy so can you think of anything she
did she wanted kids to read right wasn't
that her thing it did do we have any
proof that the literacy rates went up or
that she actually did anything even
while she was there much less six years
later I don't think there's a lot of
people investing time and particular
Bush to make sure that she wasn't you
know yeah she was show a bomb on that
list yeah there are three there are
three africa three black women on this
list which i think is pretty pretty
impressive uh and uh but what do you
guys make of Hillary because to me it's
like everyone is so over her already
every time I read an article about her
you can actually see it now media is
starting to turn on her but they're
gonna come back we have so much to know
that's that's that's weird living in our
political bubble most people don't pay
any attention to any of this [ __ ] yeah
they don't know they don't think they're
still don't know that she was Secretary
of State they may think she already is
president yeah I mean you know that with
all the most people are not so that's
they're just asking name someone famous
until they come a Hillary has a lot of
mind share in the sense that she's been
around for a long time yeah and um and
the fact that she's number one on this
list I mean I I get it I mean just like
Obama being number one on the other list
right they're just the most widely
recognized people and Hillary is known
for being smart I mean everyone everyone
thinks she's smart and no one thing
she's dumb and even if you hate her you
think she's smart and that she's
accomplished so I I get it okay I mean
that's a much more reasonable thing to
have on the list then let's say Laura
Bush but even condi rice I mean why she
on this list for 2014 issues on the list
you know six years ago I get it but
right now it just tells you how how
dated everything is and that the you
know once she'd become famous for any
reason whatsoever whether you're in
politics or movies or whatever it is
you're just on this list forever so if
they did so next year Connie recipe on
this list next nine to ten of those
you're gonna be the same one so I guess
the one that that I know you guys are
gonna be happy about so Elizabeth Warren
being on there that's actually a sign of
something right because we're the one
you know well supposing it was number
three I know people who say Malala those
are ones i give credit to that's
impressive they know Malala i mean i
kind of get pissed off because she's
like done more at 16 than I will ever
accomplished in my entire life but
nevertheless those are people that know
yeah I made it on the route report yeah
and so but that gives me a little bit of
hope I didn't really see any hope really
on the the men's list yeah ben Carson
Billy Graham uh but but Malone that's
great I admire that yeah i am i fired
that actually shocked that she's so high
the list right III love it I but yeah
the other one on the list that's absurd
is what's with Angela Jolie and and
Princess Kate right well again that's
just purely what you're saying about
name name recognition Selena Jolie has a
reputation as being a real humanitarian
yeah it's a lot of time in babe she's
adopted half of the orphans in Africa
and that's something yeah right she got
that double mastectomy and she's a
spokesperson for for cancer and yes and
she's a humanitarian but still it's not
like saying Jennifer Aniston not to take
anything with Jennifer Aniston but yeah
she did not but I love the Brad Pitt
inbred pouch internet it did take pretty
good weight so last night is just
getting back to his own for a second um
do you think she has any realistic
chance in 2016 do you think there's any
chance that they yeah you really think I
think there's all she's gonna be like
the howard dean like she'll get
everybody really excited and then
something will happen that'll just it'll
just kind of disappear no i think well
you wall she has a lot of grassroots
support and you know it's interesting
well it'll be interesting to see how the
establishment reacts to that right
because her biggest threat is actually
not even the republicans is to stop this
establishment democrat right they're
gonna they're gonna destroy her yeah so
clinton and that whole machinery will
come after her if she decides to run so
it's really her decision as to whether
she wants to fight that battle vs
and perhaps be a total outcast in the
Democratic Party establishment or
whether she wants to fight that and be
the champion of the people I hope she
chooses the ladder we'll see